foreign
so one thing Jade I feel like we we both
enjoy good social media and yes and now
that it's everywhere all the time uh
there's a lot of people giving Financial
advice out there and so we always we
always have a good chuckle it's like I
love it and I hate it but at the same
time you were saying earlier like Rachel
I keep seeing this thing so I was like
let's talk about it Jade okay so I mean
we're in the finance space so you know
the people that you follow tend to be in
your same world even if you don't have
the exact same views it's like okay like
I follow other money people and I gotta
tell you Rachel there's somebody that I
follow and it's just so frustrating to
me because a lot of her posts are about
women having their own finances separate
from their men but it's in a way that's
a little bit secretive right and okay
don't get me wrong if you're not married
and you're just living together or it's
your boyfriend yes keep your money
separate but if you're married I believe
that you should work together with your
finances you should combine things and I
know that this person's point of view
like I know like their background they
were hurt in a relationship and all this
but I just feel like the advice is not
where it needs to be and I as a married
person you know keeping money aside
secretive I for me that's a that's
that's Towing the line there you know
that's keeping secrets and like keeping
all of your assets in your name I mean
what's the message that that's sending
the message is I don't trust you
I don't see of I don't see a for sure
future here so I'm just gonna keep mine
over here in my pocket and my account
and you don't touch it is that really
the way the footing that you want your
relationship to be on I mean and what's
and what I think a lot of a lot of these
people I think you may have said this
earlier you know that it's it's a lot of
fear yeah it's so it's living in a lot
of fear yeah and and again are there
situations that you want to be smart
right if there's you know you talk to
someone that came out of a domestic
abuse situation right if there's
something like that going on or an
addiction I mean there are these these
points they're okay I'm gonna be smart
but overall you guys for majority of
couples yeah working together it's a
it's amazing the level of communication
that's created yes the level of trust
that happens and the just the Oneness of
marriage that you're experiencing even
with your money and the facts tell us
that I mean there's studies that say
couples who communicate openly about
money tend to feel that they're on the
same team it says quote feeling like
you're on a team together with your
partner promote relationship
satisfaction and so I do think that
there's a way as a woman because we're
all talking about all the women things
today there is a way to feel like you
have and not to feel like it but to
actually have actually have equal
footing equal say and God forbid if
something happens you don't get left out
in the cold yes right Rachel I mean I
for me it's knowing what's going on with
your money making sure that you are
combining everything making sure that if
you're purchasing a house it's not just
in his name it's in your name too making
sure that if there's retirement accounts
you're the beneficiary on everything so
for me it's more of approaching the
money in a way that I know exactly
what's going on I'm not ignorant to the
situation I know it's going on as
opposed to I'm just gonna have my life
over here and you know what have you and
I know for me when I first got married I
was the woman that was kind of the other
end of the spectrum that was like I
don't know what's going on I don't care
he brings in the money you know and I
really thought like oh ignorance is
Bliss right right ignorance is not Bliss
it is broke yes and you will end up
broke and then you won't even know how
you got broke so I can't say it enough
that the solution to the problem is not
is not going off on your own and and
being secretive with money hiding your
money having secret accounts I'm not
against having your own
piece of money out of the budget right
right like having a line item I mean I
have line items Jades Jade's fun and
Jade's yes hair and Jade's grooming
that's fine you know and I don't have to
tell Sam okay I spent 12 on shampoo
right I'm not saying that I'm not saying
that you have to be controlled but I am
saying that you should share your
finances yes absolutely because the
benefits it it it's beneficial right if
it was harmful all the time then we'd
probably have different advice you guys
but yeah but the benefit of what we've
seen day in and day out and even you
know we quoted 10 million people have
gone through Financial Peace University
right like we work with literally
millions of people that have done this
plan and it's one of the top comments
that we get that our our marriage feels
closer yes and there's something about
it you guys of combining so if you
haven't yet we we encourage it we really
do and I love that the science backs it
up too it does have that conversation
have those tough conversations